is one of our favorite guests and I'm
not just saying that because he's on the
phone line right now and we also had the
man he's fighting against in Madison
Square Garden in UFC 230 and we're fair
and balanced so when we invited Derrick
Lewis to be on our show in studio last
week we're like we definitely got to get
Daniel Cormier back on the program and
the only fighter other than Conor
McGregor and UFC has sure to be a
champion to to division simultaneously
is here on the program Daniel Cormier
are you doing DC I'm good man how you
doing rich I'm about there alone there
the other day and he crushed it well
that's that's what he does right that's
what he does with everything that's in
front of him usually that is the case
right that massive flower but he's also
got a really really big personality and
and you know in fight sports man
sometimes it's about what you put out
there into the world and what you have
inside of the Octagon that gets you in
these positions that isn't today okay so
what is your concern stepping into the
Octagon with him just a big power I mean
you know I've been on your couch before
and I've been next to you in the studio
and you know I'm not the biggest guy but
there at Lewis is massive he's a big
strong athletic guy that can can win a
fight with one punch so there's never a
time in the Octagon where you can feel
safe when you're fighting a Derrick
Lewis yeah so what is your approach then
how do you deal with something like a
threat like that I think I just have to
be myself you know I didn't get to where
I am today by by playing it safe
III think I can beat their equitable
stand up fight if it turns into a
stand-up fight I just know that I don't
make their types of mistakes that some
of the guys have made against it I've
said this on a number of occasions on
which it's like football or throwing up
the ball from the other side of the
court there is no Christian Laettner
shot to win the national championship
there's no Hail Marys when you fight a
guy like me you have to be able to beat
me I don't think they're yeah so what is
the mistake that you saw others make
volkov everybody helped make well I
thought
what was he doing he was wondering with
20 seconds left
all we had to do is just not stand in
front of them and get clipped upside the
head she could have just circled for 10
seconds and won the fight
literally just circle imagine if you're
Alexander Volkov right now this
opportunity weapon his we could be
staring across the Octagon at each other
at Madison Square Garden on Saturday if
he would have circled for 15 seconds he
beat Derek Lewis for 14 minutes and 30
seconds of that fight but for some
strange reason he stood in front of them
to end it and God not though okay so
that's that's one guy that's one guy
what else have you seen I guess on with
your own two eyes or on tape mm-hmm
Marcin tempura Marcin typer another guy
was beating Derek Luce up then decides
to start wrestling with him guys not a
Russell he's a striker what has happened
to him knockout like these guys make
these mistakes they put themselves in
the danger area in with Derek it only
takes one he hurts him so bad that they
don't recover you got to be smart mark
hunt was smart mark hunt didn't bother
taking him down he like Derek fight to
the point that he exhausted himself
niches finished it was beautiful you
just got to be very smart against a guy
like that Daniel Cormier here on the
Rich Eisen show before he takes on
Derrick Lewis do you think Derek is get
would have gotten this fight if he
didn't have that post match conversation
with Joe Rogan they went viral because
of how hilarious it was what do you
think you know what that's the crazy
thing it's like I'm not sure he wouldn't
had this opportunity but the problem is
he deserves it because Alexander Volkoff
was the number three ranked guy in the
world he beat him in July when I won the
Belfast IPE he be friends and Gandhi was
ranked number one in the world so if you
beat three in one in year two you would
think that you deserve a title shot but
he probably would not have gotten it if
not first and in the Octagon in his
underwear and talking about his boss
being hostile
so crazy Oh crazy in this world of
social medias what a comment by
that can can concern into I understand
that is that that's wrote Rogen
understands we all understand there's no
doubt about it
Daniel I we we were talking about it the
next day just like everybody else but I
view it as in terms of looking at it
from Rogen as a broadcaster as somebody
who's interviewed thousands of people in
crazy situations never expecting to hear
an answer like that and his answer to
say he that he understood I understand
is truly a thing a genius I would say
yeah because you don't even know what
this thing in the back like what do I
face it is I understand like okay Joe so
you said in the commentary table of all
the sweaty crazy it was magic it was
absolutely magic I was in the arena and
people rich you could see people taking
their phones out going to Instagram and
going follow of all of all of all and
Derek Lewis's followers jumped up um
five six hundred thousand overnight
happy he did that so then I guess it
stands to reason for me to follow up
with you Daniel what was your
perspective when all holy heck broke
loose with Conor McGregor and khabib
hopping fences and everybody hopping
fences and and fists flying what was
your perspective there rich so like I'm
sitting right next to the Octagon I
jumped the fence right because your
initial reaction is to help your friend
but when I got up there was like what am
I thinking
so when I got to Hobby he's yelling and
he's screaming he's odd the security's
grabbing him I mean it was absolute
pandemonium I look at him and the
security trying to ignore this you know
so finally he goes this is my capital
let him talk to me let him talk to me so
I look at him in the midst of all this
recycle what in the world are you doing
hey what are you doing what are you
doing he goes I go just quit you gotta
calm down
I go what are you doing but it was just
such madness that there was a guy
sitting behind me of
man that really doesn't follow in the
mail that much because he asked me who I
was going for not knowing I'm teammates
with a beat
after the fight I'm in the Octagon
trying to call my beef now this guy had
jumped the fence and was checking on
Conor McGregor once he was in the
Octagon he was rich he was in the
Octagon the guy was in the Octagon like
making sure Conor was ok so I asked my
wife I go who was that guy was he part
of kind of team
she goes Daniel he was a fan because
after all that was happening so he just
walked back out of the kids got back
over the rail and got back in the seat I
was like holy smoke security and the
cops are so worried about everybody else
that they didn't even notice that guys
do that it was crazy so let me just
review here let me review here some dude
just chat you up has clearly no idea
about you could be the sport he was just
there just probably because he knew it
was a big night in the sports world it's
Las Vegas and so yeah you hop the fence
to help cubby I guess after he got back
in to the to the ring I guess to me into
the right away like soon as he jumped
the fence we all jumped the rail me and
Rob okay ran to go try to see what was
happening okay guy was dressed for the
time right like he looked like he could
be part of kind of do you know they're
always dressed alike right he followed I
guess and when everybody was jumping the
fence he just followed it made it all
the way to the optimum it was a crazy
signal I can't remember the guys name
but on Twitter there's videos of him in
the Octagon like giving his friends a
thumbs up they're filled with him so
dude crazy so let me let me ask you this
then do you think Habib's gonna get back
in the Octagon he's and what what is he
doing
you know tiptoeing tap-dancing or making
nice with Floyd I mean what's this all
about then Daniel I don't know what this
thing is with Floyd honestly I think you
know obviously you fight of Floyd
Mayweather you make a ton of money and
ultimately that's what guys want to do
right from basketball to football to MMA
everything it's about making money
and if it what they where the fight was
to present itself can't be like
everybody else would entertain it well
yesterday Dana said something to the
fact of we're not playing this game with
you anymore Floyd you want to fight one
of our guys I'm with you see that that
seemed to be the end of it but as we've
seen in the past you never truly know
what's going on there's only a few
people in the know and you know I think
there'll be some some some uh some more
clarity to that whole situation a little
bit later I just think there's too much
money involved to not get McGregor and
ANCA be back in the Octagon I just think
it's there's too much interest too much
at stake too much going on too much
natural bad blood to not see something
like that play out again
DC let me ask you a question i grin so
but here's the difference right watch
the competition yes let a competition
hmm what in that fight makes people want
to watch them fight again it's what
happened afterwards that goes we gotta
put these guys back in there because in
the actual fight right we've killed him
you didn't but because of all the
extracurricular we're all like we gotta
see him again
it's insane because it's almost like
this thing worked out to the benefit of
the fight yeah I know and but and that's
why at least gave Dana white credit for
for having an immediate face voice of
contrition right off the top saying that
this is not what they were looking for
what they're hoping I mean obviously
there's a lot of business and liability
reasons for all of that but I also think
people would have wanted to see it again
just because they saw him aggregor got
his ass beat to be honest with you
Daniel and and so many people were
interested in seeing that or didn't want
to see it and want to see this one more
time and see McGregor and him face off
before etc III think there might have
been his interest but you're right that
that also might be a window into our
society about what makes us interested
you know the thing about Conor is for as
popular energy is redemption would be
much sweeter so maybe that's the draw
people going wow our hero
beat up let's see him come back and beat
what has become essentially an
unbeatable guy but hats off the kind of
thing if it's not could be right away
give me the next guy I'll earn my way
back to him it was a competitor well
last time we spoke to wrap up our
conversation here Daniel Cormier here on
the Rich Eisen show you were here you
were saying that the end was near that
your family was wondering why you wanted
to still fight now you you are taking on
Derrick Lewis there's John Jones still
out there as we all know your history
with them you are verbally seeming
inviting Brock lesner into an octagon
with you Daniel what is your future hold
from to UFC 230 and on I mean did we got
us that's the beauty in being in my
position you know the FBI's John's we
have the Lesnar option and these are two
of the most lucrative fights that I
could make so competitively if I'm
looking to write everything that's been
wrong my career is John Jones in terms
of financial there is no fight like
fighting Brock Lesnar so we're gonna
have to really weigh that after the
fight so if you could pick one which one
would you do you only could choose one
as a right now they'll probably Lesnar
you know what something do it's a big
fight it brings a lot of prestige and
it's it's just when you're next to Brock
Lesnar at the top of the bill you know
it's a big moment Brock's a special
attraction it's like when we were kids
and Andre the Giant showed up things
it's a it's a big deal when you fight
Brock Lesnar alright last thing I'm not
not that you need any extra motivation
against Derrick Lewis but when he was
here on the show a guy from New Orleans
who was now moved to Houston and says
he's adopted two Texans and he's left
the Saints behind and your Saints as we
all know are looking superb taking on
the Rams this very week yeah do you
resent that sort of approach to football
from your terrible UFC opponent it's a
it's terrible that Derek
take that approach because Derrick come
on you know he knows and he's old enough
to remember that the Saints were all we
had the things for all we had Louisiana
there was no baseball team there were no
pelicans it was the Saints or it was
nothing it is embarrassing man a guy
from New Orleans could say something
like that so yes he does need to get it
a little bit more for the Saints
well you show a man Daniel you show them
and I've always loved our Jets I really
enjoy our chats and you versus Derek
Lewis is going to be some great must see
stuff on Saturday night at Madison
Square Garden which is as we all know a
jewel on the Sports Arena world so enjoy
it soak it in thank you so much rich I
appreciate you always have an angel
always you bet at DC underscore MMA
Daniel Cormier the heavyweight and light
heavyweight champion of UFC right here
on the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience